yeah it shouldn't be like enterism it's
like tax to tourists you know that's
nice that's all it is text the right
tourists
I mean you know you can pass for
Hawaiian I know that's why I'm like
don't text me dude just like in Turkey
it's like if you if you look at you are
yeah
[Music]
all right we've mentioned this a couple
times but I think it's best to focus on
this topic
solely and um I want to know obviously
what you think Joe uh about Hawaii
what do you think of the Hawaiians that
want to end tourism
oh that's a tough one man it is tough
because
right now okay so this so for people
that don't know
um the way Hawaii became a state is a
really weird ugly history messed up yeah
because Hawaii was a kingdom a Sovereign
Nation that was recognized by a lot of
like European nations into the U.S
and then
um the U.S was doing business with the
Kingdom of Hawaii a lot of uh rich
like farmers and plantation owners in
the west coast they went over there and
they started doing sugar cane pineapple
and they built the whole industry out
there
and then so the way that they actually
took Hawaii from the royals is
um they conspired to basically create
like a military coup
by calling the U.S government over and
saying oh we're in trouble something
something and then they went in and then
they uh basically took the kingdom and
made it a U.S territory against the will
of the people yeah and so the way that
it was done it was like an illegal
overthrow it wasn't so if you look at it
by today's standards uh you would it
wouldn't fit well with the UN and and
like their their would be a sanctioned
movie it wouldn't it wouldn't and that's
why
um I think it was Bill Clinton or one of
the recent presidents made a formal
apology and a statement and they
recognized that it was not Kosher the
way that it was obtained so
that's why there's um sentiment there
between the residents of
um how they feel about should it be a
Sovereign Nation or should it still be
along a part of the U.S and then so I
think for us like on the mainland we
don't I mean we just we just think all
states are States but they're now there
there's that sentiment between the
native population and possibly like
long-time residents
um and I know the the feelings of both
like one of my
um Bible teachers at my church she's
born and raised in Hawaii has ties to
like Plantation kids that worked in the
fields and all that and for her she was
excited that Hawaii became a U.S state
whereas certain native sentiments
they're like no this is like absolute
defeat that we became a U.S state so
that's the that's the whole feeling
right
fast forward to today now you have so
much conflict between how Hawaii uh what
status Hawaii should be right some
people believe
um we should be a we should go back to a
Hawaiian like Sovereign
they should secede uh but the native
population is less than like six percent
so that's another thing too right so
like the demographic there isn't big
enough to hold majority vote so they'll
never actually be able to do it legally
yeah interesting and then also there's
so many different
groups within the Sovereign Hawaii like
like within the native cultural groups
right there's different uh ideas of how
to handle it and I watched uh PBS
episode where they brought all these
different leaders of you know Hawaiian
ancestry groups and they couldn't agree
on how to move forward some people were
like we should be our own country
because it was already illegal from the
start so don't participate don't vote
don't do any of that stuff because that
recognizes that we are a part of the US
oh because you're participating in the
Democratic politics okay they're like
it's already wrong to be to to be uh to
begin with the other part uh she was
saying um no we're already like
practical like practically we're here
like there's no freaking way that we're
gonna go back
to becoming our own Nation the U.S
military is here everything is here we
get so much federal aid and she goes the
best route for us is actually to try and
get indigenous status and then we can
get more funding and more help from the
government right and then I think
another person was talking about how
they're like no I think what we need to
do is own the land privately so if we
could privately own the land as a group
then we can control it regardless of
what nation is here so I'm like they had
a lot of legitimate like philosophies or
like methods on how to go forward but I
think that's the difficult part is like
you don't have one group with one
solidarity like one idea
and and so I think it's like a difficult
Journey for the native Hawaiian
um figuring out how to like
get their house in order and what
mission they want to do so out of those
three things that you mentioned that
they're like these three factions want
there's more than three but that's who
were invite who is invited to the PBS
debate out of all of those do do any of
those
um the average person that's in Hawaii
that is saying stop all tourism does
that help any one of those agendas to
just stop it I don't they didn't really
address that but right now after the
fire in Lahaina a lot of people were
hurt so they didn't want anyone to come
and just like have a fun time it all
started because this snorkeling group
yeah was they had a chart like a
snorkeling trip in the same Waters less
than 24 hours ago people drowned and
died escaping from the fires and they
posted on Instagram saying um oh we were
just trying to do a fundraiser and we
were oh they responded yeah the people
that were snorkeling yeah they're like
sorry like we just wanted to do that as
a way to like give and everyone's like
you're [__] foolish oh [__] yeah it
was interesting and then so we had like
Hawaiian music artists we had Jason
Momoa we had all those people announcing
like hey guys don't visit Hawaii right
now they're hurt like how dare you like
have your weddings and celebrate and do
all this stuff while they're in pain
yeah then a couple of days after local
native Hawaiian and also like just just
local people that live in on Maui
they're like
why are you guys saying this like you
guys are celebrities and Rich and you
can [__] pay for all of this stuff
you're not tied to the industry he goes
I look I do like sightseeing trips
that's all we you know and we have 20
employees and none of them can work
right now or like I have a small little
family-owned hotel or like I have a
little restaurant that relies on this
and we're like passed on bills yeah and
then and then they're like we need we
need this tourism to stay here in our
community so there's like conflict there
too there's no clear sentiment of like
what should happen
yeah I wanted to ask like so
being that that whole fire that had just
happened and stuff like that and them
not getting any like support whatsoever
um do you think that kind of plays a
role into why they're being so like hey
we don't want to be a part of the States
you guys can't even support us you can't
even support your own
Ukraine which is the benefit of like
what yeah what's the benefit I think
that further proves like why the federal
government fails Hawaii like the locals
there are they were way quicker to yeah
like they said FEMA Red Cross and all
that was there but everybody there knows
that who made the biggest impact were
the locals that were like oh these
people haven't ate in like two days but
there's like all this government red
tape right because they probably have to
look at the where is this coming from is
it safe can we pass it out whereas the
locals there we're like are you gonna
block the roads uh all of us are going
to get our boats load up all the stuff
and then people are going to meet us
there pass it out and then they were
feeding them some people want jet skis
with a bunch of supplies and then I
think when people are quicker to do that
then they're like we don't need you guys
because the bureaucracy is slower
yeah dude that's I think that's a big
thing like so I was looking into this
right because I was like yeah why don't
they just fight the government harder or
like how come it is the way that it is
and then so
um Hawaii's like the like the lowest
five states that do uh voter like
participation oh so a lot of people
aren't they're like pathetic about
politics no I think like so they call it
the plantation mentality out there where
like the way Hawaii culture like after
the native right the way that it Crea
that that it I guess evolved or what it
is today is it's the plantations that
developed the the community there so
rich Plantation owner and some of them
are descendants of missionaries of all
these like sugar and pineapple like cnh
and dull big ass names right they
um brought over a lot of different
cultures to work on their Plantation
Filipino Japanese Portuguese Mexican and
then that's where they created the
society where like the current Hawaii
culture is like based on a little bit of
native a little bit of Asian a little
bit of whatever right it's the most
mixed state of mixed background
ethnicity with Multicultural like most
people out there that are local they're
like over three four mixes
and then they're the they might be the
majority actually they're like 30 or
something like that
so they have their like I think that's
why the state identity is so strong in
my opinion where they don't connect with
the mainland in that sense so like
whether you're like Japanese or Chinese
or whatever everybody identifies as like
a Hawaii local first before an American
so I think there's that and then there's
also the native population who who's
like
they identify as like Hawaii NATO
but yeah I think it's that's why that's
there's all these nuanced like groups
you know that like it's that's and I
think those things are more important
than like
American or U.S government
and then um
the the things that they celebrate too
like is different like they don't go
hard on Thanksgiving they don't go hard
like Fourth of July like it wasn't even
that that big whereas like on the
mainland like the bit in California the
biggest supporters of Fourth of July is
Mexicans you know what I mean like it's
I think it's just a different it's a
different mentality where they're not
fully like hardcore or U.S yeah yeah so
do you think when when uh I mean not
just Hawaiians but just people are
outside looking in telling everyone to
stop going to Hawaii stop stop tourism
doesn't it seem like something else
should happen after that there should be
a plan before you just stop tourism like
what would be the best case if tourism
were to end four Hawaiians that want
sovereignty
yeah me and my buddies all like that
live there we talk about this a lot
actually because like
so they say that uh
they replaced like the plantation with
tourism right so the big money makers
used to be they're all gone they all
they all set like um sugar plantations
and pineapple to the South America
and yeah and just less than I think five
years ago uh cnh they produced a lot of
the uh sugar cane in in Maui they left
which is also why there's a lot of fires
because when their fields were not
maintained anymore all these tall grassy
fields and it's kind of similar to
California where it's dry yeah
um and then every summer there's like
always like brush fires
so that's also another way too because
they didn't do good Land Management
after they left and then to supplement
the income now tourism is thriving right
or like Land Development and you know
whatever so like
once you have a dependency on a certain
amount of income then you have to
replace it some other way right and then
so we're like
how can the state probably be
self-sustaining if they want to
have less tourism right because you now
people it takes the place you're not
gonna yeah but what they possibly can do
is look at
island nations that became successful
and I would I look at Singapore yeah or
you know I would look at even Israel
they're not an island nation but they're
like a small group that can make a big
impact so like what can the state of
Hawaii do and I think Tech is one
because you don't need resources for
Tech you just need a lot of people
focusing on yeah and with work from home
you know like remote work you could do a
lot of coding you could do a lot of
things like related to that
Finance I think like
there's about half a million
uh I guess people with native Hawaiian
um
like ancestry so if you start a fund as
a group everybody puts in a grand or
something you already got a native fund
right there that you can start
purchasing things and
you know investing so I think like if
you can figure out
um more methods of making income it will
probably supplement but you can't if you
have a beautiful place you can't have
people not come they're going to want to
come yeah that that's a hard part I
don't think you can like end tourism
like your your blessing is your curse in
that sense right like no matter what
like Hawaii's [__] beautiful it's
like Island Paradise magic Vibes all
that stuff I got a lot of money coming
in for that yeah you know for the same
reason why sometimes like people like
hate LA and you still come in you're
like [__] the weather's great you know
what I'm saying like your people are
gonna come yeah and we're not like a
tourist state but we still have so many
people come all the time right so I mean
I don't think you could stop it I think
managing it or like managing the
expectations of everybody or figuring
out how to like better preserve the
island like sure there's maybe progress
that can be made but I don't think they
can like end tour that makes sense I
feel like that is a good restrictions
like how like we're trying to you have
to have like a visa to go there or
something
sure yeah I think that might be a good
way is like controlling curbing it a
little bit Yeah because like so Oahu
um which is the island I'm on you'll see
a lot of skyscrapers so it feels like
you know a city on a little island but
if you go to all the other ones you
don't really see that many
um tall hotels and it's because they
have city ordinances where you can't
build can't develop that and you have to
have a visual to the water or like they
have these rules and some people might
be like oh that's too controlling but
I'm like no that's kind of good because
there's such small resources right right
yeah or it's also like you know uh
raising prices is like a way to like you
know curb that as well it's like every
single year when more people or when
inflation changes what do they do at
like Disneyland they like raise the
prices you know what I mean they raise
it just enough to make it so that their
capacity always kind of stays the same
right it's like a strategic you know
every time as much as it in one sense
sucks it's like well you're you're
limiting certain people's ability to get
there so yeah you're managing the
population density of that tourism you
know and aside for that there's things
called like price tied of paradise you
know em Tangi the guy that just won uh
American Idol so he used to uh live in
this area called Kahuku and him and his
family had to move out and this is a
huge thing where like they call Las
Vegas the ninth Island because a lot of
local people from Hawaii
have to
um just they're just they can't afford
it yeah it's too it's stupid expensive
because it's like you're basically
having to pay Silicon Valley prices for
homes
um but your income is like
basically all working class service jobs
right so then how do you even afford a
million dollar home it's more expensive
than here in LA and on top of that it's
not just the home prices it's everything
so like groceries going to Walmart or
anything right at least in La like it
might be expensive housing but you can
find discount food you can find things
exactly right so your money can stretch
right whereas like Hawaii you're kind of
screwed it's just they don't have a lot
of things yeah what you get yeah and
that's also what
um the hotel industry and just people in
general are facing like when you don't
have a working class who's gonna work
those jobs because now all you you have
a bunch of retired dentists that are
taking up your neighborhood they're not
working they're not working they have a
ton of money to maybe invest so like my
classes know where to live exactly and
then you have all these empty celebrity
homes right so like they drive up the
value and it's an island and when you do
comps like comparisons for Real Estate
the way that it works is you see how
much these homes sold in your area but
because it's an island and everything is
so small you might be next to a 20
million dollar house so that's affecting
your your real estate that's why you
have a 700 square foot Shack for two
million dollars
right damn that's that was built in 1930
and it's like got roaches all over yeah
that's ridiculous that's so hard I guess
the the interesting response to when
people are saying and tourism is and
replace it with what right
well I think a lot of people that are
angry they don't really have a grasp on
the economy cause and effect on you know
everything right they're just thinking
like [__] these people coming and having
a good time when we're hurt yeah stop it
right I mean there's just a lot of
emotions going on yeah I mean so many
people in in any circumstance they focus
on the problem but very few present any
kind of solution yeah yeah and I and I
don't blame them because they don't and
it's hard they don't know like are they
economists like are they City officials
like do they see things from top down
like they might just be just working and
then one day all their family members
just lose [__] and they're like seeing
people having fun and then they're like
why are you here you know like I get it
yeah it's a lot of misdirected anger but
I think everyone's mad at the wrong
things yeah that is interesting when you
bring in the the fact that their own
local government fails them and there's
so much corruption and then they're mad
at tourists and then they're mad at
tourists yeah it's like like bro we just
come here yeah yeah that's it I mean if
I was working in that Chrome government
I would be like yeah be mad at the tour
yeah yeah yeah
focus on them yeah no one's really yeah
I don't know
but it's it's a hard thing to answer
because it all kind of does make sense
and it all doesn't right like I can get
with the people that are like [__] the
tour is because I'm like yeah to a
degree it is because they don't care
about they literally they literally
don't care that's why they're here yeah
but it's uh and also yeah and also yeah
it shouldn't be like in tourism it's
like tax the tourists you know that's
nice that's all it is that's the right
tourists not me I'm not me not me though
I mean you know you can pass
I know that's why I'm like don't text me
dude just like in Turkey it's like if
you if you look at you are yeah